Sal Vulcano is one-quarter of the
tenderloins the comedy troupe at the
heart of the true TV show Impractical
Jokers which has been on air since 2011
if you've somehow never seen it before
the series follows volcano and as
longtime friends James Murray Joe Gatto
and Brian Quinn as they compete to be
the last man standing in public
practical jokes challenges
examples include cutting in line in
ludicrous ways soliciting for hilarious
fake charities and even straight-up
insulting strangers just to see what
happens I'm just gonna say howdy the
results are always awkward but the Joker
has to do it the loser faces punishments
and it's almost always worse the gangs
friendship must be pretty ironclad for
them to be pals after regularly
tormenting each other over the course of
a decade how did it all come together
this time let's focus on Sal Vulcano and
see what he was doing before Impractical
Jokers
took off born in 1976 in Staten Island
New York
Salvatore Sal Vulcano is the only
brother to three sisters Kellyanne Diane
and Jenna the last of whom has actually
appeared on Impractical Jokers
and even married Murray as a prank I
James Murray take you Sal's sister
Sal's parents Sal Vulcano senior and
Diane Fernandez Vulcano divorced when he
was very young between them volcano has
Italian Cuban and Puerto Rican roots
volcanoes fate as a comedian began to
take shape when he was a teenager in the
90s when he began attending the private
Monsignor Farrell high school their
volcano participated in several sports
was a member of the Chess Club and in
his junior year joined the school's
improv Club where he met the other three
men that would in adulthood become his
best friends and Kostas unlike the
reputation that cultivate on screen
Valle carne when the other boys are
remembered as being rather respectful
young men in high school a fact they
often bring up themselves as to why they
never perform Frank's too out of line
touches right touch destroy
now between 2010 and 2014 sour pusses
background as a bartender and his
finance degree from st. John's
University to use as business manager
for a bar called full cup a well-known
music and comedy venue in his home
borough that had gone through several
owners in its long local history after
Impractical Jokers catapulted him into
the national spotlight
he sold his stake in the bar in 2014 and
sadly the business soon struggled to
survive it was rebranded as a hashtag
Bar and the new management in 2016 and
ultimately closed later that year turns
out that was pretty important to keeping
the place afloat as Sal's former
business partner Bubba Parker told sy
live in 2016 my famous partner left me
Sal was a professional business guy so
when he left it was really hard along
with that work volcano assisted friend
and fellow Staten Island local Jay
Miller with writing for his longtime
local access comedy talk show mid
evenings with Jay Miller a Staten Island
entertainment institution that gives
local musicians and other talent a
platform David Letterman style the two
got on so well creatively that so asked
Jay to join Impractical Jokers as a
producer in 2013 I just want to say you
are number one in my book before landing
the lucrative TV deal that became
Impractical Jokers selling the others
toured and performed live shows as
comedy quartet the tenderloins
they also self produced sketch comedy
content for a number of years during the
early days of YouTube the channel is
still active and many of their oldest
videos are available to watch if you've
got a free afternoon to dive into a
decade's worth of memories
[Music]
that sketch-comedy work got them
significant attention first in the form
of a failed scripted comedy pilot for
Spike TV and then the television deal
with truTV for the series that
eventually became Impractical Jokers
with all their previous material
available online as a proof of concept
as well as their professional background
touring they were given unusually
generous creative control as executive
producers for their first big deal
television for a if the best improv is
fostered through a sense of trust
volcano and the Impractical Jokers boys
certainly have it and that's all thanks
to time and experience with trust comes
the understanding that when conflict
comes they can manage it between each
other a Sal explained in a reddit AMA of
course we fight from time to time but we
are so used to it it's never personal if
that isn't an ultimate statement on the
strength of this foursomes friendship we
aren't sure what is it must have been
fate for the four of them to spend their
lives doing this to each other and it
couldn't be more charming to watch check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos but your
favorite TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and at
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]